People really were different back in the '60s. Here is something that it is impossible to imagine any politician saying today-- any successful, mainstream, big-time politician anyway. Listen to the President of the United States, June 4, 1965.
在60年代，人们确实与众不同。这里有一段话，放在今天，你不可能想象任何政客会说出口——至少任何成功的、主流的、重量级的政客都不会。请听1965年6月4日，美国总统的一段发言。
Perhaps most important is the breakdown of the Negro family structure. For this, most of all white America must accept responsibility. It flows from centuries years of oppression and persecution of the Negro man.
也许最重要的问题是黑人家庭结构的瓦解。对于这一点，美国白人必须承担主要责任。这是数世纪以来对黑人男性的压迫和迫害所导致的后果。
In 1965, black single mothers became a national political issue, a national symbol, for the very first time. And it was the Democrats who put the issue on the table. A young Assistant Secretary of Labor named Daniel Patrick Moynihan submitted a report to President Lyndon Johnson calling for national action, to do something about the large number of black single mothers.
1965年，黑人单身母亲首次成为一个全国性的政治议题和一个国家象征。将这个问题摆上台面的正是民主党人。一位名叫丹尼尔·帕特里克·莫伊尼汉的年轻劳工部助理部长向林登·约翰逊总统提交了一份报告，呼吁采取全国性行动，去解决大量的黑人单身母亲问题。
When large numbers of men grow up in homes without strong male authority, the report said, it leads to chaos, crime, violence, and unrest. Black single mothers, the report declared, were at the center of quote "a tangle of pathology in the black community." Black leaders, including the Reverend Doctor Martin Luther King, Junior, did not take too kindly to all this. They said that all this talk of black pathology had unfortunate racist overtones, and the issue dropped from the national scene for years.
报告称，当大量男性在没有强大男性权威的家庭中成长时，会导致混乱、犯罪、暴力和不安。报告宣称，黑人单身母亲处于所谓的“黑人社区病态纠葛”的中心。包括马丁·路德·金博士在内的黑人领袖对这一切并不买账。他们表示，所有关于黑人病态的言论都带有令人遗憾的种族主义色彩，此后多年，这一议题便从国家舞台上消失了。
Then the Republicans picked it up. Ronald Reagan talked about welfare queens. Dan Quayle said the LA riots happened mainly because of a breakdown in traditional family structure. For two decades, the entire national debate over welfare reform has often seemed like it's really just a referendum on inner city single mothers, which brings us to Barbara Clinkscales.
后来，共和党人重新拾起了这个话题。罗纳德·里根谈到了“福利女王”。丹·奎尔说，洛杉矶骚乱主要是因为传统家庭结构的瓦解。二十年来，整个关于福利改革的国家辩论，看起来往往就像是对内城单身母亲的一场全民公投，这就引出了芭芭拉·克林克斯凯尔斯。
We gave Barbara Clinkscales a cassette recorder. And for seven months, she taped her family's life. And the story we bring you today, her life in her own words, it isn't that it completely contradicts everything in the national debate over single mothers, though sometimes it does contradict that debate. It's more that when you hear her talk, the national policy discussion somehow seems irrelevant and off the point. It's as if the policymakers have no real picture of what a life like hers is really like.
我们给了芭芭拉·克林克斯凯尔斯一台卡式录音机。在七个月的时间里，她录下了家人的生活。今天我们为您带来的这个故事，即她用自己的话讲述的生活，并不是说它完全反驳了关于单身母亲的国家辩论，尽管有时确实如此。更多时候，当你听她诉说时，那种全国性的政策讨论似乎变得无关紧要，甚至偏离了重点。就好像决策者们根本无法想象她那样的生活到底是什么样子的。
Today, we devote our entire program to her story. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天，我们的全部节目都将贡献给她的故事。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Like most African-American single mothers, like 77% of them, Barbara Clinkscales works for a living. She has a job in the new information economy as a data entry operator. And she's so committed to seeing that her kids graduate high school that when her son, Gerald, cut some classes, she started escorting him to class herself, telling his classmates, "My name is Barbara. I think we'll be seeing a lot of each other from now on."
像大多数非裔美国单身母亲一样——大约占77%——芭芭拉·克林克斯凯尔斯靠工作养家糊口。她在新的信息经济领域拥有一份工作，担任数据录入员。她非常致力于确保孩子们高中毕业，以至于当她的儿子杰拉尔德旷课时，她开始亲自护送他去上课，并对他的同学说：“我叫芭芭拉。我想从现在起，我们会经常见面的。”
Before we start her story, some quick statistics to put all this in perspective. Barbara's family is not unusual at all. There has been a radical shift in American family structure. The number of children born to black single mothers has risen from 17% in 1950 to 70%, seven zero, in 1994. The number of white children born to single mothers has risen even faster, from 1.7% in 1950 to 25% in 1994. Here, then, is the story of one single mother told in her own words.
在开始她的故事之前，先提供一些简短的统计数据来衡量这一切。芭芭拉的家庭一点也不特殊。美国家庭结构发生了根本性的转变。黑人单身母亲所生子女的比例已从1950年的17%上升到1994年的70%（七零）。白人单身母亲所生子女的比例上升得更快，从1950年的1.7%上升到1994年的25%。现在，这是一个单身母亲用她自己的话讲述的故事。
OK. Hi, I know we late. I'm sorry. Yeah, it's my fault this time.
好的。嗨，我知道我们迟到了。我很抱歉。是的，这次是我的错。
Let me introduce myself. My name is Barbara.
让我自我介绍一下。我的名字是芭芭拉。
Good morning, Miss Clinkscales.
早上好，克林克斯凯尔斯小姐。
Hi baby, good morning.
嗨宝贝，早上好。
I'm a single mom. I have three kids, Angie, Tess, and Gerald.
我是一名单亲妈妈。我有三个孩子：安吉、泰丝和杰拉尔德。
Good morning.
早上好。
Angie's 25. Tess and Gerald are 17. They are twins. They're in high school, in the 11th grade.
安吉25岁。泰丝和杰拉尔德17岁。他们是双胞胎，在读高中十一年级。
Hi, my name is Barbara Clinkscales. Everybody knows me.
嗨，我叫芭芭拉·克林克斯凯尔斯。每个人都认识我。
Yeah, I know that name from somewhere, Clinkscales.
是的，我在某个地方听说过这个名字，克林克斯凯尔斯。
Yeah, I always bring him to school. And I stand here while he goes up to his locker, and he comes back.
是的，我总是送他上学。我站在这里等他去储物柜拿东西，然后再回来。
Every morning, I take Gerald to school. If I don't take him to school, he'd get up, get dressed, and he'd just sit there. He won't go. In order to take him to school, I have to go a half hour out of my way in the opposite direction of my workplace. Then after I leave his school, it takes me another 50 minutes to an hour back past my house before I get to work. Altogether, it takes me an hour and a half to two hours to get to work in the morning.
每天早上，我都送杰拉尔德上学。如果我不送他，他起来穿好衣服后就只会坐在那儿。他不去上学。为了送他，我得绕道，比去单位的方向多花半小时。送完他后再去上班，还要再绕过我家，再花50分钟到一个小时。总之，每天早上我得花一个半到两个小时才能到单位。
But I'm sorry, Mr. Maybaum.
但我很抱歉，梅鲍姆先生。
That's OK, everyone's right out here. Last week, almost every afternoon-- I'm going to go get my book-- he did not come to my afternoon classes. Let me go get my book.
没关系，大家都站在外面呢。上周，几乎每天下午——我去拿我的书——他都没有来上我的下午课。让我去拿书。
OK. Where were you? Where were you?
好的。你去哪儿了？你去哪儿了？
I was at school.
我在学校里。
You stayed in school, but you just didn't go to his class?
你待在学校里，只是没去上他的课？
That doesn't sound like it makes any sense, does it, Gerald? Where did you go if you stayed in school?
这听起来说不通，对吧，杰拉尔德？如果你待在学校里，你去哪儿了？
The twins don't go to school in the neighborhood we live in. I had to borrow my coworker's address to get them into Bogan High School because I feel Bogan High School is a real good school. They really care about the kids, and they work with you. Like Gerald's teacher, Mr. Maybaum. He cares about Gerald as if Gerald was his own child.
双胞胎并不在我们居住的社区上学。我不得不借用同事的地址让他们进入博根高中，因为我觉得博根高中是一所真正的好学校。他们真心关心孩子，而且配合家长。比如杰拉尔德的老师，梅鲍姆先生，他像关心自己的孩子一样关心杰拉尔德。
Where have you been going? Come on. You might as well tell us. No big, dark secret, is it? Where you been going?
你一直去哪儿了？过来。你最好告诉我们。这不是什么不可告人的大秘密，是吧？你一直去哪儿了？
Where did you go last week? Gerald, are those hickies on your neck?
你上周去哪儿了？杰拉尔德，你脖子上那是吻痕吗？
No.
没有。
Yes, they are. What a-- Turn around. You see that, Mr. Maybaum?
是的，就是。什么——转过身来。你看到了吗，梅鲍姆先生？
What's that?
那是什么？
That's what he's probably doing. Those are the love passion marks, hickies.
他可能就是在做这个。那些是爱的印记，吻痕。
Could be. Could be.
可能是。可能是。
If I hit you upside your head, you'll know what they are.
如果我揍你的头，你就知道那是什么了。
Right now, all I can focus on is the twins and getting them through high school. Get them through high school.
现在，我唯一能专注的就是这对双胞胎，让他们高中毕业。让他们高中毕业。
Now we're walking him down to the other end of the school to the counselor's office, Mr. Ware, where he'll have to reinstate Gerald because of those two cuts.
现在我们正送他去学校另一头的辅导员办公室，也就是韦尔先生那里，他得因为那两次旷课恢复杰拉尔德的资格。
When I talk to them about graduating, I always tell them, when they walk across that stage, I'm going to do a cartwheel. And my best girlfriend, she says, she's going to do a split. And the twins look at us and laugh. And they say, they want to see this. And I say, well, I better start practicing because I know you guys are going to walk across that stage.
当我和他们谈论毕业时，我总是告诉他们，当他们走上那个舞台时，我会做一个侧手翻。我最好的闺蜜说，她要做一个劈叉。双胞胎看着我们大笑，说他们想看。我说，好吧，我最好开始练习了，因为我知道你们肯定会走上那个舞台。
OK, what I was doing, that moment of silence, I was writing my name and the time, signing in, on the sign-in sheet in Room 102. I'm sitting here next to Gerald waiting.
好了，我刚才在做什么呢，在那默哀时刻，我在102教室的签到表上写下我的名字和时间。我现在正坐在杰拉尔德旁边等着。
I always dreamed about going on a prom, all the senior activities that the seniors do when they graduate from high school. I didn't get a chance to go on a prom because when I was graduating from high school, I had my own apartment. I had been out on my own ever since I was 16 years old. So I had to play grown-up. But I can live some of my dreams through them. That's why I feel the way that I feel, that nothing is going to get in my way, nothing.
我一直梦想着参加舞会，参加所有高中毕业生参加的活动。我没有机会参加舞会，因为我高中毕业时已经自己住公寓了。从16岁起我就独立生活了，所以我不得不装作大人。但我可以通过他们来实现我的一些梦想。这就是我感觉的原因，没有什么能阻挡我，什么都没有。
You really think you're smart, Gerald, don't you? You really think you're getting away with something, don't you? Do you think I'm going to give up? Huh? Do you think I'm going to give up? Gerald, I'm talking to you.
你真觉得自己很聪明，杰拉尔德，对吧？你真觉得你能瞒天过海，对吧？你以为我会放弃吗？哈？你以为我会放弃吗？杰拉尔德，我在跟你说话。
I'm going to kill you, Gerald, and sit up in jail before I let you be out there on them streets, no education, a dymie, trying to deal drugs to have some money. I will take your life and sit up in jail gladly. Because I'm not going to live day to day, knowing my only son is a failure. All right?
杰拉尔德，我宁愿杀了你，然后坐在监狱里，也不会让你流落街头，没受过教育，像个小混混，试图兜售毒品赚点钱。我会夺走你的生命，然后心甘情愿地坐牢。因为我不想一天天地过日子，还要知道我唯一的儿子是个失败者。行吗？
[SOUND OF A BASS LINE AND GLASSES CLINKING]
[低音伴奏和玻璃杯碰撞声]
My landlord is playing his music. I'm standing here just holding the mic. I have a portable bar because I like to collect pretty glasses. And that's just how the music is vibrating through the floor. Really, noise don't bother me. When you grow up in the projects, noise just don't bother you. You can live with it.
我的房东在放音乐。我站在这儿拿着麦克风。我有一个移动酒吧，因为我喜欢收集漂亮的杯子。这就是音乐透过地板震动的声音。真的，噪音困扰不了我。当你成长在廉租房社区时，噪音根本不会打扰你。你能适应它。
And my apartment is real big. I have three bedrooms, living room, dining room, a nice long hallway. And I'm walking into Gerald's room now. And you get-- why? I can't come in here?
我的公寓真的很大。有三间卧室，客厅，餐厅，一条漂亮的走廊。我现在正走进杰拉尔德的房间。你弄——为什么？我不能进来吗？
What you putting on the radio?
你在收音机上放什么？
Well, they can't see you.
好吧，他们看不见你。
But it's going to be on the radio, though.
但这会被广播出去的。
Well, you should keep it clean if you don't want nobody to know your room is dirty.
好吧，如果你不想让别人知道你的房间很乱，你就应该保持整洁。
People will be hearing it?
人们会听到它吗？
Yes. Everything we talk about from now on, your whole life, is going to be on the radio. People are going to know how you don't want to go to school, how your momma have to take you to school every day, watch you go in your classroom.
是的。从现在开始，我们谈论的一切，你整个生活，都会在广播里播出。人们会知道你多么不想上学，你妈妈不得不每天送你去学校，看着你走进教室。
So I'm in my living room now. And I'm having company tomorrow, so we going to clean up tonight. And I can't wait for Tess to come home because I worry about her being out at night. But I can't stop her from doing the things that she want to do. But I really don't have no peace until she walk through that door. And then I feel better.
我现在在客厅里。明天我有客人，所以我们今晚得打扫干净。我迫不及待地想让泰丝回家，因为我担心她晚上在外面。但我无法阻止她做她想做的事。但在她走进那扇门之前，我真的无法安宁。然后我才会感觉好些。
OK. I guess I'll start cooking them tacos. I promised that I'd cook tacos for dinner.
好吧。我想我该开始做墨西哥夹饼了。我答应过晚餐做夹饼的。
[SOUND OF THREE GUNSHOTS]
[三声枪响]
Oh god, did you just hear that? They're shooting. Oh god, don't let that be Tess. Oh god, I hope Tess is not outside. Gerald, get away from the windows.
哦天哪，你刚听到了吗？他们在开枪。哦上帝，别让那是泰丝。哦天哪，我希望泰丝不在外面。杰拉尔德，远离窗户。
[SOUND OF TWO GUNSHOTS]
[两声枪响]
Gerald, just come in the hall. Come in the hallway, Gerald.
杰拉尔德，快到走廊里来。到走廊里来，杰拉尔德。
[SOUND OF THREE GUNSHOTS]
[三声枪响]
Gerald?
杰拉尔德？
What?
什么？
Where are you at?
你在哪儿？
Oh god, I hope Tess is not out there. Oh god. Crime and drugs is everywhere, but I know my block is the crack block. Just wait, Gerald. Wait 'til the shooting stops.
哦天哪，我希望泰丝不在外面。哦天哪。犯罪和毒品随处可见，但我知道我的街区是毒品交易区。等着，杰拉尔德。等枪声停了。
I always lived in the area. But I moved right on the worst block. I just moved smack dab in the middle of hell, pick-up hell. And he put me right in the middle. That's my block.
我一直住在这个地区。但我搬到了最糟糕的街区。我就搬到了地狱中央，接客的地狱。他把我安置在正中央。这就是我的街区。
Gerald, is that the police or ambulance? Do you see anything?
杰拉尔德，那是警察还是救护车？你看见什么了吗？
No.
没有。
Oh god. It sounded like somebody coming up the steps.
哦天哪。听起来好像有人上楼梯了。
That's probably Tess.
那可能是泰丝。
[SOUND OF THREE KNOCKS]
[三声敲门声]
Who is it?
是谁？
It's me.
是我。
Oh god, it's Tess. And they just got through shooting, so that means she had to be getting off the bus on 79th Street. Tess, did you hear the shooting?
哦天哪，是泰丝。他们刚开完枪，那意味着她肯定是在第79街下的公车。泰丝，你听到枪声了吗？
When?
什么时候？
They was just finished shooting.
他们刚刚开完枪。
For what?
为什么？
They was outside just shooting.
他们在外面开枪。
I didn't hear it.
我没听到。
Father, thank you again.
上帝，再次感谢你。
She was praying for me?
她在为我祈祷？
Yeah, I was praying. They was just shooting. You could have got caught up in that. Where are you just coming from?
是的，我在祈祷。他们刚才开枪了。你可能被卷进去了。你刚从哪儿回来？
The library.
图书馆。
Come up close. I can't hear you.
靠近点。我听不见你说话。
Doing research on Thurgood Marshall for me English class.
为我的英语课做关于瑟古德·马歇尔的研究。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
Tess and Gerald are twins, but they are totally opposite, like night and day, sweet and sour. Tess is the dominant twin. She knows what she want, and what she have to do to get it. Tess was on the cheerleaders. She was on the swim team. She worked at Seaway Bank. I never, never had to take Tess to school.
泰丝和杰拉尔德是双胞胎，但他们完全相反，就像昼与夜，甜与酸。泰丝是强势的那个。她知道她想要什么，也知道必须做什么才能得到它。泰丝参加了啦啦队。她参加了游泳队。她在海路银行工作。我从不需要，从来不需要送泰丝上学。
What time you got to go to work?
你几点去上班？
I got to be at work at 9 o'clock.
我得9点到工作地点。
I don't have to wake you up.
我不必叫你起床。
No.
不用。
So you get up on your own?
所以你是自己起床的？
Give me a Tasmanian alarm clock. That's what I want.
给我一个塔斯马尼亚闹钟吧。那就是我想要的。
OK, her name is Tess. And they call her Taz. So she loves Tasmania, anything with Tasmania. If you come over and you see her room, she have Tasmania posters, Tasmania blankets, pillows, clothes.
好的，她的名字是泰丝。他们叫她Taz。所以她喜欢塔斯马尼亚，任何带有塔斯马尼亚的东西。如果你过来看看她的房间，她有塔斯马尼亚海报、毛毯、枕头、衣服。
Underwear, socks, pictures.
内衣、袜子、照片。
Tess have so many of my ways. She eat like me. She think like me. She dress like me. And these are things that just come natural, not things that I teach her. It just come natural.
泰丝有很多我的习惯。她吃东西像我。思考方式像我。穿衣风格像我。这些都是自然而然形成的，不是我教她的。这是与生俱来的。
Is this for me?
这是给我的吗？
Yeah, no, wait 'til you eat. Now what about your diet?
是的，不，等吃完饭再说。你的节食计划怎么样了？
Forget my diet. Everybody like me the way I am.
忘掉我的节食计划吧。大家都喜欢我现在的样子。
Oh Lord. First, she was all depressed. She said her arms was too fat.
哦天哪。起初，她很沮丧。她说她的手臂太胖了。
They still is. Look, I still want to get my arms sucked.
现在还是。看，我还是想把手臂吸脂。
Some boy done told her that she looked good, so she don't care about-- she want liposuc-- what you call that?
有个男孩说她看起来很漂亮，所以她不在乎——她想要抽脂——你管那个叫什么？
My arms sucked. I don't know what it's called. I think it's called liposuction. But I just want to get my arms sucked.
把我的手臂抽脂。我不知道那叫什么。我想叫抽脂手术。但我只想把手臂抽掉脂肪。
Oh, OK. Go turn that skillet off. I'll go and cook the tacos.
哦，好的。去把平底锅关掉。我去煮夹饼。
People always ask me, do I have picks with my kids, who I like the most. And people always tell me, I know you're proud of Tess. I know that's your pick. But you know, Tess is not my pick. I don't have a pick.
人们总是问我，我有偏心吗，谁是我最喜欢的孩子。人们总是告诉我，我知道你为泰丝感到骄傲。我知道那是你的最爱。但你知道吗，泰丝并不是我的最爱。我没有最喜欢的。
Angie's not my pick. Gerald is not my pick. I love my kids the same. They all special in they own way.
安吉不是我的最爱。杰拉尔德不是我的最爱。我同样爱我的孩子们。他们每个人都有自己的独特之处。
Angie, I had Angie at 15. And I was a baby having a baby. I was 15. I didn't know nothing about raising kids. I knew nothing about life. But I was determined to stay in school and to graduate and to raise Angie.
安吉，我15岁时生的安吉。我还只是个孩子生孩子。我才15岁。我什么都不懂，关于养育孩子。我对生活一无所知。但我决心留在学校，毕业，抚养安吉。
And it was just me and her against the world. And I did it. Even though she dropped out of school and had babies and everything, but she's still a good person. She's my first born.
那时只有我和她面对整个世界。我做到了。尽管她中途辍学，有了孩子，等等，但她依然是个好人。她是我的长女。
And Gerald is mommy's man. That's my son. All my life, I never had a father. I never had a brother. And so only time I ever loved a man was in a relationship.
而杰拉尔德是妈妈的乖儿子。那是我的儿子。我这辈子，从未有过父亲。我从未有过兄弟。所以我也只在恋爱关系中爱过男人。
And when my son was born, that's a man who loves me unconditionally. His love is just because I'm his momma. It's not because he wants something from me. It's not because he wants sex or something. A man finally loved me for me.
当我儿子出生时，那是一个无条件爱我的男人。他的爱仅仅因为我是他妈妈。不是因为他想要从我这儿得到什么。不是因为他想要性爱什么的。一个男人终于因为我本身而爱我。
And Tess, she's a carbon copy of me. In other words, she's a young me. And you would think she's my pick, but she's not.
至于泰丝，她是我的翻版。换句话说，她是年轻时的我。你会以为她是我的最爱，但她不是。
Come on, let's make a toast.
来吧，干杯。
To the Hens.
为了母鸡小分队。
Everlasting, never-ending sisters.
永恒的，无止尽的姐妹们。
The Hens are a group of ladies that's been friends since high school. We do all kind of stuff together. We laugh, we talk, we watch movies, we get in trouble.
母鸡小分队是一群从高中起就是朋友的女士。我们一起做各种事。我们大笑，聊天，看电影，闯祸。
OK, wait a minute. It spells out something. What do it spell?
好的，等一下。它拼出了什么。拼出来是什么？
Never-ending, everlasting sisters.
永恒的，无止尽的姐妹。
H-E-N-S. H-- hens.
H-E-N-S。H——母鸡。
Some of the most fun we have is when we go away. We leave the kids, the husbands, the job. We leave everybody. Rent a room, and eat, laugh, and talk, and just don't do nothing. And our next big trip is to Jamaica.
我们最开心的时刻就是去度假。我们放下孩子、丈夫、工作。我们抛下所有人。租个房间，吃饭，大笑，谈天，什么都不做。我们下一次的大旅行是去牙买加。
And we have been planning and paying for this trip since October of last year. And whenever the Hens are sitting around, talking about our trip to Jamaica, we end up talking about our fantasies, and what we're going to do when we get there. Every Hen has a different fantasy about Jamaica and what they want to do.
自从去年10月以来，我们一直在计划并为这次旅行存钱。每当母鸡们坐在一起谈论我们的牙买加之行时，我们最后总会谈到我们的幻想，以及我们到了那儿要做什么。每个母鸡对牙买加以及她们想做的事都有不同的幻想。
My fantasy is on the beach, a big, black piano, with this man in a white jacket, and I name him Sam, playing the piano, playing love songs. Y'all know this? And me leaning over it with a exotic drink. And me constantly saying, "Play it again, Sam."
我的幻想是在沙滩上，一台黑色的大钢琴，有一个穿着白外套的男人，我叫他山姆，在弹钢琴，弹着情歌。你们都知道这个吗？我靠在钢琴上，手里拿着一杯异国情调的饮料。我不断地说：“再弹一次，山姆。”
When I go out with my girlfriends, and I meet men, and we go out, especially on one of those hoochie mama nights-- hoochie mama can mean a lot of things. Sometimes we'll call ourselves, yeah, we're going to be hoochie mamas tonight. That mean we going to dress sexy. We don't overdo it, just show a little cleavage, a little legs, something with a split. And I go out, and I meet men, they just love me. They just all over me. But they don't know that that's the evil twin, my evil twin.
当我和闺蜜出去，遇见男人们，我们出去玩，特别是在那些“浪荡女”之夜——浪荡女可能意味着很多事情。有时我们会说，是的，我们今晚要做浪荡女。那意味着我们要打扮得性感。我们不会过度，只是露一点乳沟，一点腿，或者穿件开叉的裙子。我出去遇见男人，他们就爱死我了。他们全都围绕着我。但他们不知道那是邪恶双胞胎，我的邪恶双胞胎。
Everybody know about my evil twin. One of my coworkers found out about my evil twin, and he laughed because they know Barbara the hard worker, the mom, the grandmother. But every now and then, the evil twin will slip out at work. But when I go out, the men meet the evil twin.
每个人都知道我的邪恶双胞胎。我的一个同事发现了我的邪恶双胞胎，他笑了，因为他们只知道努力工作的芭芭拉，那个妈妈，那个祖母。但偶尔，邪恶双胞胎会在工作中溜出来。但当我出去时，男人们见到的是邪恶双胞胎。
The night we get to Jamaica, I'm going to get out on the balcony. And then I'm going to let all them Jamaican men know that I'm there. And I'm going to do the Xena yell.
我们到牙买加的那天晚上，我会走到阳台上。然后我会让那些牙买加男人们知道我在那里。我会发出《战士公主》西娜那样的尖叫。
You do that Xena yell, and they're running away.
你发出那种西娜尖叫，他们会逃之夭夭的。
No, baby, not that Xena yell. Barbara standing out on that balcony in that gown, and my hair flowing in the wind, no, baby, nuh-uh.
不，宝贝，不是那种西娜尖叫。是芭芭拉穿着长袍站在那阳台上，头发在风中飘扬，不，宝贝，没那回事。
But when they get to know me, when they see that evil twin was just that personality for the moment, that night, out partying, dancing, living. And then they get to know the serious me, the mom, the hard worker, the grandmother, they get kind of turned off. And they constantly refer back to the night we met, that personality.
但当他们真正了解我之后，当他们看出那个邪恶双胞胎只是那一瞬间的性格，那晚出去狂欢、跳舞、生活。然后他们认识了严肃的我，那个妈妈、努力工作的人、祖母，他们就会感到扫兴。他们总是回头谈论我们初次见面的那个夜晚，那种性格。
What's yours, Tiny?
你的呢，泰尼？
Mine's is dirty.
我的很脏。
It ain't clean, huh?
不干净是吧？
It ain't clean.
不干净。
I know when I talk to them on the phone after we have met. And they call me up, and I try to have decent conversations with them. And they want to know, "How do you make love? What's your favorite position? How often do you like to make love?" I'm like, "That's none of your business." I'm like, "Do you have kids? Where you work at? Are you religious?" I want to talk about these things, and they get turned off. They don't want to talk anymore.
我知道在我们见面后，我在电话里和他们聊天。他们给我打电话，我试着和他们进行体面的谈话。而他们想知道：“你是怎么做爱的？你最喜欢的姿势是什么？你喜欢多久做一次爱？”我就说：“那不关你的事。”我说：“你有孩子吗？你在哪儿工作？你有宗教信仰吗？”我想谈论这些事情，他们就失去了兴趣。他们不想再聊了。
Leah, what's your fantasy?
莉亚，你的幻想是什么？
When we go to Jamaica? Oh, just to make wild, passionate love.
当我们去牙买加的时候？哦，就是进行一场疯狂、充满激情的性爱。
My girlfriend, Peaches, she's going through the same thing I'm going through. And we said, we have PhDs in heartbreak. We can write a book on "No, that's not it." And we just sit up and we laugh and we talk. And we always tell each other, "Well, one day, we going to be at each other's wedding. We going to be standing up there, looking at each other walk down the aisle in love and happy."
我的好朋友皮奇斯，她正在经历和我一样的事。我们说，我们在心碎方面都有博士学位。我们可以写一本书叫《不，那不是真的》。我们就坐在那儿大笑，聊天。我们总是告诉对方：“嗯，有一天，我们要参加彼此的婚礼。我们要站在那儿，看着彼此穿着婚纱走过过道，坠入爱河，幸福美满。”
And so why are we here? We sit up and talk about our PhDs. And we add a new chapter to our book. It just doesn't seem to fail. I don't know.
那么我们为什么要在这儿呢？我们坐着谈论我们的博士学位。然后我们又给我们的书加了新章节。这似乎没完没了。我不知道。
Come on, Rosetta.
来吧，罗塞塔。
Oh no, mine's is too, too, too outrageous.
哦不，我的太……太离谱了。
Well, tell one of the nice things.
好吧，讲一点点好的部分。
I don't have nice things like that. I have great fantasies, great fantasies.
我没有那种好的东西。我有伟大的幻想，伟大的幻想。
Just a walk on the beach.
就只是在沙滩上散散步。
They cannot be told.
不能说。
It's Monday morning. Tess has gone to school. We're running late, so I called a cab. I called the livery. It's like a person owning his own car, and he drive it as a cab. These cab companies only work throughout the black neighborhood.
是周一早上。泰丝已经去学校了。我们迟到了，所以我叫了一辆出租车。我叫了私人租赁车。就像一个人拥有自己的车，当出租车开。这些出租车公司只在黑人社区内运营。
Gerald, did you get you a bus pass? Your school ID? Did you ever find your school ID? OK. Did you lock those bars? You turn off the iron? So I'm going to go downstairs and wait on the cab. They said, four minutes. A grate leaking. Come on, Gerald.
杰拉尔德，你买公交月票了吗？你的学生证？你找到学生证了吗？好的。你锁上那些护栏了吗？你把熨斗关了吗？所以我要下楼等车。他们说四分钟。有个地沟漏了。快点，杰拉尔德。
I'm in the living room with Gerald. I'm just getting home from work. He was watching TV, so I thought I'd talk with him.
我正和杰拉尔德在客厅。刚下班回来。他在看电视，所以我想到跟他聊聊。
Have you been cutting any more classes?
你还有旷课吗？
No.
没。
Do you still hate that school?
你还讨厌那个学校吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Why?
为什么？
People start so much stuff.
人们老爱惹事。
What kind of stuff do they start?
他们惹什么事？
They be talking stuff. If I do talk back, they act like they about to jump on me.
他们老是嚼舌根。如果我回嘴，他们就像要扑上来揍我一样。
Would they be thinking about jumping you outside?
他们会想在外面围堵你吗？
Yeah. They kill people.
是啊。他们会杀人的。
I know.
我知道。
That's what they talking about doing.
他们谈论的就是要做那事。
Killing you?
杀你？
Yeah.
是啊。
Just for talking back?
就因为回嘴？
Yeah.
是啊。
What do they say to you?
他们对你说了什么？
They just be starting stuff.
他们就是爱找茬。
Like what? Just out of the--
比如什么？就平白无故地——
Like they call you names. And I call them back. And they be like-- they jump hard, and I jump hard back. Five more guys come up on me, telling me, what y'all want to do then?
比如他们叫你难听的绰号。我也回骂。他们就——他们开始挑衅，我也回击。又有五个人冲上来，问我，你们想怎么样？
Jump hard? What you mean jump hard?
开始挑衅？挑衅是什么意思？
This means they-- you know--
就是他们——你知道——
They ready to fight?
他们准备打架了？
Yeah.
是啊。
Jump hard mean they jump up to you with their fists up in--
挑衅意思就是他们挥着拳头冲到你面前——
Yeah, they want to pull it. That mean they want to fight you.
是啊，他们想动手。意思就是他们想跟你打架。
They want to pull it.
他们想动手。
Yeah, that's slang for they want to fight you. That's why I was cutting a few classes. Because if I did when I went to school, I probably would have been beat up by now.
是啊，那是想跟你打架的俚语。所以我才旷了几节课。因为如果我去学校，我现在可能已经被打了一顿了。
[SOUND OF SOMEONE MAKING A TELEPHONE CALL]
[拨打电话的声音]
Hello?
喂？
May I speak to Marvin? How you doing?
我能跟马文说话吗？你好吗？
Marvin. I met Marvin through my Auntie Susie's boyfriend, Grantey. Grantey is from Jamaica And he's been telling me about his nephew, Marvin, and Jamaica for a long, long time. He always told me that Marvin would be the perfect, perfect man for me. But I never paid him any attention. And one Sunday morning, Grantey called me around 7 o'clock in the morning, saying, he just got back from Jamaica, and he had pictures and a phone number, and his nephew wanted me to call him. And I laid in bed, and I tried to go back to sleep, but I couldn't. I couldn't go back to sleep.
马文。我通过姨妈苏西的男朋友格兰提认识了马文。格兰提来自牙买加，他一直跟我提起他的侄子马文和牙买加。他总是说马文是我的完美伴侣。但我从来没在意。有一个周日早上，格兰提在早上7点左右打电话给我，说他刚从牙买加回来，有照片和电话号码，他侄子想让我给他打电话。我躺在床上，试着睡个回笼觉，但我睡不着。我再也睡不着了。
That's your favorite picture of me? You have it with you? OK.
那是你最喜欢我的照片？你随身带着吗？好的。
So I called him. And when I heard his voice, I went into a trance. It was like I knew him all my life. This was the man for me.
所以我给他打了电话。当我听到他的声音时，我进入了一种恍惚状态。感觉就像我认识他一辈子了。这就是我要找的男人。
Yeah, I love that song. Ooh, I used to cry over that song. You do? Well, I got to play it. I want to see you cry.
是的，我喜欢那首歌。哦，我曾经因为那首歌哭过。你也是？好吧，我得放一放。我想看你哭。
After talking to Marvin for about a week, he asked me to come to Jamaica. And I got real scared because talking to him on the phone is a security blanket because we're on the phone. We're not in person. And I'm older than him. Marvin, he's 28. I'm 41. And being an older woman, being full-figured, and what if I get there, and he don't like me because I'm older, because I'm a full-figured woman?
和马文聊了大约一周后，他邀请我去牙买加。我真的很害怕，因为在电话里和他说话有一种安全感，因为我们在电话里。我们没有面对面。而且我比他大。马文，他28岁。我41岁。作为一个大龄女性，又是丰满体型，如果我到了那儿，他因为我年纪大、因为我身材丰满而不喜欢我怎么办？
Those songs make you cry just like they make me cry.
那些歌让你哭，就像让我哭一样。
When I tell him these things, he know how I feel. But he says, it don't matter. He fell in love with my personality, the way I think, and the things that I believe in. He said, it really don't matter. So it's time. I'm going to Jamaica. It's June 6.
当我告诉他这些事时，他知道我的感受。但他却说，那不重要。他爱上的是我的个性、我的思考方式，以及我的信仰。他说，那真的不重要。所以是时候了。我要去牙买加。现在是6月6日。
I love you too, baby. Yeah. Bye. Here, Gerald, get the keys. I forgot the flowers. What's that, Gerald? Where the flowers? The bag is on the microwave that-- Gerald.
我也爱你，宝贝。好的。再见。来，杰拉尔德，拿钥匙。我忘了花。那是什吗，杰拉尔德？花在哪儿？袋子在微波炉上，那个——杰拉尔德。
What you gonna do?
你要做什么？
We getting ready to go see Gerald go on his girlfriend's prom.
我们要准备去看杰拉尔德参加他女朋友的毕业舞会。
With Keisha?
和基莎一起？
Yeah.
是啊。
I never want to prom because I couldn't afford it really. I really couldn't afford it.
我从来没参加过舞会，因为我真的负担不起。我真的负担不起。
Mamma.
妈妈。
What?
什么？
That's the dog that bite me.
那就是咬我的那只狗。
Yeah, that dog gonna bite you. Now get in the car.
是啊，那只狗会咬你的。快上车。
I always wanted it. I said, my kids is going to do the things that I didn't do. And when Angie didn't graduate from high school, it hurt me so bad. I was like, oh God, my kid's going to follow in my footstep. And then with Tess and Gerald, and I made a pact with them, and I made a pact with God that they going to do  this. They going to do it for me, and they going to do it for them.
我一直想要那种体验。我说，我的孩子们要去做我没做过的事。当安吉没能高中毕业时，我太伤心了。我就想，哦上帝，我的孩子要走我的老路了。然后是泰丝和杰拉尔德，我和他们定了一个契约，我和上帝也定了一个契约，他们会完成这个目标的。他们会为我做到，也会为他们自己做到。
What's wrong, Gerald? You nervous? Huh, Gerald? Look how he holding the flowers like they're a little, bitty baby. You nervous, Gerald?
怎么了，杰拉尔德？你紧张吗？哈，杰拉尔德？看他拿着花的样子，像拿着个小婴儿似的。你紧张吗，杰拉尔德？
Nuh-uh.
没有。
You're not nervous?
你不紧张？
Because I told Tess, I said, your prom dress is going to be rent. Your shoes gonna probably be the phone and light bill. We're not going to have any food that month, and we might have to live in a shelter. Because I'm not paying no bills when it come time for her to go to prom.
因为我告诉泰丝了，我说，你的舞会礼服会是租的。你的鞋子大概会花掉电话费和电费。那个月我们没饭吃，还可能得住收容所。因为在她去参加舞会的时候，我不会去付任何账单的。
Lock the doors. Put the locks on.
把门锁好。把锁扣上。
Angie and her friends are talking about crashing the prom, take pictures of Gerald sitting at the table, take pictures of Gerald dancing on the floor, take pictures of Gerald taking pictures. We're so excited. It's not even his prom. But we're going to live our dreams through the twins.
安吉和她的朋友们在谈论去舞会捣乱，给杰拉尔德坐在桌边拍照，给杰拉尔德在舞池跳舞拍照，给拍照的杰拉尔德拍照。我们太兴奋了。尽管那甚至不是他的毕业舞会。但我们要通过这对双胞胎来实现我们的梦想。
OK. We're standing outside of Keisha's house. Gerald's ringing the doorbell.
好的。我们站在基莎家外面。杰拉尔德在按门铃。
Do you have your socks, Gerald?
你带袜子了吗，杰拉尔德？
Gerald's going to get dressed at her house. He don't have his tux on. I fantasize about Gerald being a man all the time, being a father, working. I have these pictures in my mind, what he's going to look like when he's 30. I don't do this with Angie. I never did this with Tess. But I wonder all the time about Gerald, what he's going to be like when he's a man.
杰拉尔德要去她家换衣服。他还没穿上礼服呢。我总是幻想着杰拉尔德成为男人，成为父亲，工作的样子。我的脑海里有这些画面，想象他30岁时是什么样子。我不会对安吉这样。我以前对泰丝也从没这样过。但我一直都在想杰拉尔德，当他成为男人时会是什么样子。
Give her your tux and stuff, Gerald. Don't smash your flower. Give her your tux. Uh-oh. Pick your jacket up, Gerald. Come on now. Don't let it hit the ground.
把你的礼服和东西给她，杰拉尔德。别弄坏了花。把礼服给她。哦不。捡起你的外套，杰拉尔德。快点。别让它掉在地上。
Gerald don't have a will like Tess do. Sometime I think Tess took it all from him. But I know somewhere down the line, Gerald's gonna fool me. I know it.
杰拉尔德没有泰丝那种坚强的意志。有时我觉得泰丝把他的意志全抢走了。但我知道在未来的某一天，杰拉尔德会让我大吃一惊的。我知道。
She's coming down.
她下来了。
One more, hurry up.
再来一张，快点。
OK. Now she can come down. Oh my goodness. Oh God, she's so pretty.
好的。现在她可以下来了。哦我的天哪。哦上帝，她太漂亮了。
OK, hold it, Gerald. OK, how you gonna pose? Come on. Come on, Gerald. Put your-- yeah, like that. OK, open your-- yeah, yeah, go-- Oh, look at my baby.
好的，保持住，杰拉尔德。好的，你要怎么摆姿势？快点。快点，杰拉尔德。放你的——对，就像那样。好的，张开你的——对，对，去——哦，看我的宝贝。
Oh, look at him. Oh, look at my baby. Hold it again. Hold it again, Gerald. Quickly, hold it like that. Open your-- relax, Gerald. Your hands, relax, there you go.
哦，看着他。哦，看我的宝贝。再保持住。再保持住，杰拉尔德。快，就这样保持住。张开你的——放松，杰拉尔德。你的手，放松，这就对了。
Wait, fix his jacket, fix his jacket. Close your jacket in. OK, there you go. OK, now you go. Relax. There you go, Gerald, relax. OK.
等等，整理一下他的外套，整理一下他的外套。把外套扣好。好的，这就对了。好的，现在你去吧。放松。这就对了，杰拉尔德，放松。
One day I'm going to look up, and Gerald's going to outdo Tess. And I'm going to go, "Hey, mommy's man, look at you, boy. You go, boy. That's mommy's man, hey."
有一天我会抬头一看，杰拉尔德会超过泰丝的。我会说，“嘿，妈妈的乖儿子，看看你，小伙子。去吧，孩子。那是妈妈的乖儿子，嘿。”
This is not happening to me. This is a movie. I'm dreaming. Somebody pinch me. Wake me up. This don't happen to me, no. I don't supposed to be at this moment. I shouldn't be this happy and this here proud.
这事不是真的发生在我身上。这是一部电影。我在做梦。谁来掐我一下。叫醒我。这不该发生在我身上，不。我不该处于这一刻。我不该这么快乐，这么自豪。
I know it. One day, he's going to really fool me. I claim it in your name, God. In your name, Lord, I claim it.
我知道。有一天，他真的会让我大吃一惊的。我以你的名义宣告，上帝。以你的名义，主啊，我宣告。
[SOUNDS OF BARBARA LAUGHING AND CRYING AT KEISHA'S HOUSE]
[基莎家芭芭拉又笑又哭的声音]
Oh, look at that.
哦，看看那个。
I'm home. My girls came and picked me up from the airport. And I haven't woke up from this dream yet. So maybe it's not a dream.
我到家了。我女儿们开车去机场接我。我还从没从这个梦里醒来。所以也许这不是梦。
It's late. Let me look at the time. It's like 2:00 AM. So I've been laying here for about an hour and a half, thinking about the last 11 days of my life in Jamaica with Marvin. Marvin Malcolm Craig.
很晚了。让我看下时间。大概凌晨2点。所以我已经躺在这儿一个半小时了，思考着我在牙买加和马文度过的最后11天。马文·马尔科姆·克雷格。
Marvin. He's 29 years old. Yes, and I'm 41. When I saw the movie How Stella Got Her Groove Back, I made my daughter Angie promise she wouldn't date over a certain age, and I wouldn't date under a certain age because we would never bump heads dating. And who breaks the promise? Me.
马文。他29岁。是的，而我41岁。当我看那部电影《快乐的斯特拉》时，我让女儿安吉答应我，她绝不和年龄差距过大的人约会，我也绝不和年龄太小的人约会，这样我们就不会在约会问题上产生分歧。结果是谁打破了诺言？是我。
I can't believe it. My daughter will be 26 in November. And March-- let's see, November, December, January, February, March. So he's a year and four months older than my daughter. No, two years, four months. Oh boy. Well, I don't care.
我简直不敢相信。我女儿11月就26岁了。而三月——让我们看看，11月、12月、1月、2月、3月。所以他比我女儿大一岁零四个月。不，两岁零四个月。哦天哪。嗯，我不在乎。
On my way there, I was so nervous. I was so nervous. I was so scared. But soon I walked out of the airport, I went over there to him, and he just grabbed and hugged me. And that was the beginning of my new life. Oh my God, Barbara, what have you done?
在去那儿的路上，我太紧张了。我太紧张了。我太害怕了。但当我走出机场，我朝他走过去，他直接抓住我，拥抱了我。那是我新生活的开始。哦天哪，芭芭拉，你都做了些什么？
He proposed to me, and I said, yes. He had one of his rings melted down, and made into an engagement ring, and asked me to marry him. And he inscribed "Love MC" and the date that he proposed. Oh God.
他向我求婚了，我答应了。他把自己的一枚戒指熔掉，做成了订婚戒指，让我嫁给他。还在上面刻上了“Love MC”和他求婚的日期。哦上帝。
I am so lucky. God, thank you. I know. I used to write letters to God. And I would put them in a Bible, praying for a man because I was tired of the dating.
我太幸运了。上帝，谢谢你。我知道。我过去常给上帝写信。我把它们放在圣经里，祈求一个男人，因为我厌倦了约会。
And every time I write a letter, God will give me what I wanted. And I said, oh Lord, I should have been more specific. I left out something. I got to think about this.
而且每次我写信，上帝都会给我我想要的。我说，哦主啊，我应该说得更具体点。我漏掉了一些东西。我得好好想想。
I got to think about this letter. OK, I don't want him to do drugs. OK, drink to be sociable. And my coworker, Doris Kelly, she said, "God will give you what you want. So if you want him to look a certain way, write it down there." I'm like, "Oh, I can do that?" She's like, "Yeah, it's OK."
我得好好想想这封信。好的，我不希望他吸毒。好的，为了社交可以喝点酒。我的同事多丽丝·凯利说：“上帝会给你你想要的。所以如果你想让他看起来像某个样子，把它写下来。”我说：“哦，我可以那样做吗？”她说：“是的，没问题。”
OK, I wrote down there what I want him to look like. And I always would leave something out. And you know what I left out this time? I forget to put down, "God, please let him be in the same country. And God, can you let him be kind of close to my age?"
好的，我写下了我想要他看起来的样子。但我总是会漏掉一些东西。你知道我这次漏掉了什么吗？我忘了写：“上帝，请让他住在同一个国家。”还有“上帝，你能让他和我年龄相近一点吗？”
So ladies, when you write a letter to God, you can't leave anything out. And I always leave something out. But that's OK, Father. I'm up for this challenge.
所以女士们，当你们给上帝写信时，你们不能漏掉任何东西。我总是漏掉一些。但没关系，天父。我准备好迎接这个挑战了。
There's so much. There's so much. Oh God. And the hardest thing was Marvin and I was laying in the bed. And I usually take my shower first. But Marvin took his shower first.
还有很多，很多。哦上帝。最难的是马文和我躺在床上的时候。我通常先洗澡。但马文先洗了。
And he said, "Come, Barbara. Come get in the shower." I did not want to do that. Because I would not let him see me without my clothes on because I feel my body was so ugly, stretch marks from having kids, being a full-figured woman. I know, look at your beautiful body, breasts sit up all perfect. And I sat there, holding my stomach, holding my breath.
他说：“来，芭芭拉。来洗澡吧。”我不想那样做。因为我不想让他看见我没穿衣服的样子，因为我觉得我的身体太丑了，生孩子留下的妊娠纹，作为丰满女性的体型。我知道，看看你美丽的身体，乳房耸立得那么完美。我坐在那儿，收着肚子，屏住呼吸。
And he called me, "Are you coming, Barbara? What's wrong, honey? Honey, what's wrong?" I took a deep breath, and I undressed and got in the shower.
他喊我：“你要来吗，芭芭拉？怎么了，亲爱的？亲爱的，怎么了？”我深吸了一口气，脱掉衣服，走进淋浴间。
And he just took the towel, and he just soaped it up, and washed me. And I stared at him. I kept trying to see his face, see his eyes. And all my fears and insecurities went away. He took those fears away.
他拿过毛巾，打上肥皂，帮我洗澡。我盯着他看。我一直试图看他的脸，看他的眼睛。我所有的恐惧和不安全感都消失了。他带走了那些恐惧。
And I just keep asking myself, why me? And everyone like, Barbara, why not? Why not?
我一直在问自己，为什么是我？大家都说，芭芭拉，为什么不呢？为什么不呢？
Coming up, things take a turn for the worst in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
国际公共广播电台节目继续，稍后事态急转直下。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, we are devoting our entire program to one story. Barbara Clinkscales is a single mother living in Chicago. Over the course of seven months, she recorded her family's life. In this half of the show, her story continues.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们将全部节目贡献给一个故事。芭芭拉·克林克斯凯尔斯是一位住在芝加哥的单身母亲。在七个月的时间里，她录下了家人的生活。在下半场节目中，她的故事继续。
Oh boy. I'm sitting in my bedroom on the end of my bed. I stayed at work 'til about 7:00, 7:30. I didn't want to come home. I just didn't want to deal with this problem, deal with this-- I was praying I didn't have to go through this.
哦天哪。我坐在卧室的床边。我一直工作到7点、7点半。我不想回家。我只是不想面对这个问题，面对这个——我祈祷着我不用经历这些。
So I'm just sitting here. Thought I'd just pick the mic up and talk about it. I'd call Gerald in, and we can talk about it. Tess called me, and she had Keisha on the phone, Gerald's girlfriend. And did Tess tell me she was pregnant, or did Keisha tell me she is pregnant? I think it was Tess said that Keisha was pregnant.
所以我只是坐在这儿。想我就把麦克风拿起来聊聊。我该叫杰拉尔德进来，我们可以谈谈。泰丝打电话给我，她在电话里和基莎在一起，也就是杰拉尔德的女朋友。泰丝是告诉我她怀孕了，还是基莎告诉我她怀孕了？我想是泰丝说基莎怀孕了。
I can't remember. I went into shock. I didn't say anything for about 10 minutes 'til Tess got scared. And she kept saying, "Momma, momma, momma are you there? Momma, momma?" I went into shock. I went into total shock.
我不记得了。我陷入了震惊。我大约10分钟没说一句话，直到泰丝变得害怕。她不断地说：“妈妈，妈妈，妈妈你在那儿吗？妈妈，妈妈？”我陷入了震惊。我彻底陷入了震惊。
I felt sick and dizzy. And then I just started praying. And that's when I heard Tess say, "Momma."
我感到恶心和头晕。然后我就开始祈祷。就在那时我听到泰丝喊：“妈妈。”
How do this feel? I'm trying to sum it up in words. How do this feel? I want to cry. I want to scream. Oh God.
这感觉怎么样？我正试着用语言总结。这感觉怎么样？我想哭。我想尖叫。哦上帝。
Last night, I went and picked Angie up from work. And on my way out the door, Gerald stopped me. And he was on the phone. And he said, "Momma, I have a friend, and he's named after his dad. If he have a son, would his son be the second or the third?"
昨晚，我去接安吉下班。在门口，杰拉尔德拦住了我。他在讲电话。他说：“妈妈，我有位朋友，他的名字和他爸爸一样。如果他有儿子，他儿子应该是二世还是三世？”
So I used Gerald as an example. I said, "Well, Gerald, you're a junior. Your dad is senior. He's Gerald Louis Clinkscales, number one. You're number two. And if you had a child, your son would be Gerald Louis Clinkscales the third."
所以我拿杰拉尔德举例。我说：“嗯，杰拉尔德，你是二世。你爸爸是长辈。他是杰拉尔德·路易斯·克林克斯凯尔斯，一世。你是二世。如果你有个孩子，你儿子就是杰拉尔德·路易斯·克林克斯凯尔斯三世。”
And I just walked my happy-go-lucky butt on down the steps, went out the door, got in the car. And I started up the car, and something said, I hope that fool haven't got some girl pregnant, and he was talking about himself. Then I look at the time, I'm like, oh Lord, it's 9:50, I better get out of here. And it left me. I haven't thought anything else about it until the phone call.
然后我就迈着我那没心没肺的步子下了楼，出了门，上了车。我发动了汽车，心里却有种预感，希望那个傻瓜没让什么女孩怀孕，他刚才是在讲他自己。然后我看了下时间，我心想，哦主啊，9点50分了，我最好走吧。然后那念头就离我远去了。在那通电话之前，我再没往别处想。
Oh my heart hurts so bad. My stomach hurts so bad. Oh Father, in the name of your son, Jesus Christ, I don't want to go through this. I just want to get them through one more year of high school, get them across that stage, Father, please.
哦，我的心痛得厉害。我的胃痛得厉害。哦天父，以你儿子耶稣基督的名义，我不想经历这些。我只想让他们顺利过完高中最后一年，让他们走上那个舞台，天父，求求你。
So now I have to call him in here, and talk to him, and deal with this, talk about this. What am I going to say? What am I going to say? Oh God, forgive me for this, but I don't want to deal with it. I want to act like it's not happening. Because I am so tired. I'm so tired of dealing with things.
所以现在我得叫他进来，谈谈，面对这个，谈论这个。我要说什么？我要说什么？哦上帝，原谅我这样说，但我不想处理它。我想要假装它没发生。因为我太累了。我太累于处理这些事情了。
OK, Barbara, take a deep breath. Blow it out. Call Gerald, and just say what the first thing on your mind. OK, I'm going to do this.
好的，芭芭拉，深呼吸。吐出来。叫杰拉尔德进来，就说你脑子里的第一反应。好的，我要这么做。
Gerald. Get off that phone, and come here. I'm ready to talk about it now. Tell him to call you back tomorrow. Or you may not receive any phone calls 'til you grown. 21, and I'm not talking about 18. Have a seat. So why your eyes red? You been crying?
杰拉尔德。挂断电话，过来。我准备好谈谈了。让他明天再打给你。或者在你成年之前，你都别想接任何电话。21岁，我说的不是18岁。坐下。你眼睛怎么红了？你哭过了？
No.
没有。
Why they red?
那为什么红了？
Sinuses.
鼻窦炎。
Your sinuses. So I went over to Keisha's house. She says she don't want this baby. She don't want to keep it. So how you feel about that?
你的鼻窦炎。我去了基莎家。她说她不想要这个孩子。她不想留下它。那你对此怎么看？
I feel kind of bad because I don't believe in killing babies like that. I should take care of my responsibility. And that's it.
我觉得挺不好受的，因为我不相信那样杀掉婴儿。我应该承担起我的责任。就这么简单。
No, that ain't it. How you gonna take care of your responsibility with a McDonald's job? You got to go to summer school. You gonna probably have to go to night school next year to get you out on time. Oh God, help me here. Lord, give me strength. I can do this. If you don't understand how important school is, what do you know about being a father?
不，那不是简单。你凭麦当劳的工作怎么承担责任？你得参加暑期学校。你明年可能还得去夜校才能按时毕业。哦上帝，帮帮我吧。主啊，给我力量。我能做到。如果你不理解学校有多重要，你又懂什么做父亲？
I can read the book. I can get a book about it.
我可以读书。我可以找本关于这个的书。
I have to take you to high school, Gerald.
我得送你去读高中，杰拉尔德。
I'm going every day. That's what I'm doing it for this time.
我每天都去。这就是我这次要去做的。
Well, why did I have to take you?
那你为什么还得我送你？
I was lazy back then. You want Keisha to get an abortion?
我以前懒。你想要基莎堕胎吗？
I'm not going to make that decision. I don't know. All I know is I'm not ready for you to have a baby. I wish this was a dream. I wish it'd never happen. I wish y'all was playing a joke on me.
我不会做那个决定。我不知道。我只知道我没准备好让你有个孩子。我希望这是一个梦。希望它从没发生过。希望你们是在跟我开玩笑。
I'm not going to say that. But no, I don't want y'all to have a baby. You're not ready. She's not ready. Do you think you're going to be with her the rest of your life?
我不会那么说的。但不，我不希望你们有孩子。你还没准备好。她也没准备好。你觉得你会和她在一起一辈子吗？
Didn't I ask you to be a better man? Do not bring a child into this world that you was not able to love, raise, and marry the mother. And y'all raise this child together as a family. Didn't I ask you that? Don't make the same mistakes your dad made. Be a better man.
我没让你做一个更好的男人吗？不要把你无法爱、无法抚养、无法娶她为妻的孩子带到这个世界上。你们像个家庭一样共同抚养这个孩子。我没要求你这么做吗？别重蹈你父亲的覆辙。做一个更好的男人。
That's what I'm trying to do.
那正是我努力要做的。
[MUSIC - "IF I COULD" BY CELINE DION]
[歌曲 - 席琳·狄翁的《如果我能》]
I really love this song. Sometimes I put the CD player on repeat, and I play it over and over again.
我真的很喜欢这首歌。有时我把CD机设置为循环播放，一遍又一遍地听。
I was at work. And I called Gerald. And I asked Gerald, "Have you talked to Keisha? What's going on? Is she going to have an abortion?" And he told me, "No, she's going to keep the baby."
我在工作。我给杰拉尔德打了电话。我问杰拉尔德：“你跟基莎谈过吗？发生了什么？她要堕胎吗？”他告诉我说：“不，她要留下这个孩子。”
And I just laid back in my chair at work. And I think I did it for at least 40 minutes. I just laid there. My son, Gerald, he's going to be a father. Not someone else's son. My son, Gerald. OK, I failed.
我只是靠在椅子上。我想我至少在那儿躺了40分钟。我就躺在那儿。我儿子杰拉尔德，他要当爸爸了。不是别人的儿子。是我儿子，杰拉尔德。好吧，我失败了。
My son is not ready. I can fight with him, getting him through school, getting Gerald to realize how important a career and education is. But now I got to fight with him being a father. And I know he knows nothing, nothing about being a father.
我儿子还没准备好。我可以跟他争，让他完成学业，让他意识到职业和教育的重要性。但现在我得跟他抗争关于当父亲的问题。我知道他一无所知，关于当父亲一无所知。
Angie told me that they was out in J. C. Penney, and Gerald saw this little jacket. And Gerald went, "Oh man, Angie, look, won't my little shorty look good in this jacket?" And Angie said, "Mom, I couldn't do nothing but cry." She said, "My brother's going to have a baby." And I didn't think it was cute, "my shorty." He's all proud.
安吉告诉我，他们在杰西潘尼商店时，杰拉尔德看到了这件小外套。杰拉尔德说：“哦，伙计，安吉，看，我的小家伙穿这件外套好看吗？”安吉说：“妈，我除了哭什么都做不了。”她说：“我弟弟要有个孩子了。”我并不觉得“我的小家伙”很可爱。他多自豪啊。
I just don't want to go through this again. I just can't do it. I don't have the money. I don't have the strength. I don't have time. I'm tired. I am so tired. Because all my life, it's been struggling to do this and do that. And I can give up. But I don't want to give up on my kids. I don't want them to be like they had a life like me.
我真的不想再经历一次了。我真的做不到。我没有钱。我没有精力。我没有时间。我累了。我真的太累了。因为我这一辈子都在为了做这做那而挣扎。我也可以放弃。但我不想放弃我的孩子们。我不希望他们过像我一样的生活。
Hello? Yeah, my mom told me to record something. So I'm kind of shy. So I might not say a lot of stuff. I'll just talk about me and Keisha.
喂？是的，我妈让我录点东西。我有点害羞。所以可能说不出什么。我只想聊聊我和基莎。
I had got her pregnant, I think before prom. Everybody was just mad. My mom was just mad. Her parents, they got mad. So they don't want me to call the house no more. So like that.
我想在舞会前就让她怀孕了。每个人都很生气。我妈很生气。她父母，他们也很生气。所以他们不想让我再打那个电话了。就是这样。
So my mom's staying home. We talked about it. She told me, what did I think. I was like, I wanted to have it, but her know already I ain't be going to school.
我妈待在家里。我们谈过了。她问我怎么想。我说，我想留下孩子，但她也知道我不会去学校。
Hey, block that out. Shh. Don't tell my momma. Block that out. I don't want the world to know I'm not going to school. But I'll change now, seeing as I got a kid on the way.
嘿，把那句删掉。嘘。别告诉我妈。删掉那句。我不想让全世界都知道我没去学校。但我会改变的，既然我有孩子了。
I just need a job. That's what I need. But it's hard. They be thinking I'm not trying. Ma, don't think I'm not trying this hard because my girl, Keisha, she type me up some resumes.
我只需要一份工作。那是我需要的。但这太难了。他们觉得我没在努力。妈，别觉得我没在努力，因为我女朋友基莎，她帮我打了几份简历。
Shoot. So I went out there, I gave them the resumes. And they acting like they bored. So I'm like, man. I'm calling back like, "You checked over my application or whatever?"
该死。所以我出去了，把简历给了他们。他们表现得好像很无聊。所以我心想，伙计。我打电话过去说：“你们看我的申请了吗？”
He's like, "Yeah, I'll call you. I'll call you. I'll call you back next week." And hear you, I'll be two weeks later, calling back. So that's it. It's messed up for me right now.
他回答说：“是啊，我会给你打电话。我会给你打电话。我下周给你回电。”你听着，两周都过去了，我还在打电话。就是这样。我现在处境很糟糕。
People are acting like they don't want to help nobody and stuff, acting all shisty. It's hot in here. It's 90, almost 100 degrees. Hot, sweaty, talking on microphones, stomach hurt, feel like I'm about to throw up. Talking to you about my personal life. I'm really messed up. But I messed up. Now I got to pay the price. But I just messed up. It'd be different if I didn't have no kid on the way. It's just messed up for me.
人们表现得好像不想帮任何人一样，表现得都很势利。这儿太热了。90度，快100度了。热得汗流浃背，对着麦克风说话，胃痛，感觉快要吐了。跟你谈论我的私人生活。我真的搞砸了。但我搞砸了。现在我得付出代价。但我确实搞砸了。如果我没有孩子，那会是另一回事。但我现在的处境真的很糟。
The bar is open.
酒吧开放了。
Today is my bridal shower. All the Hens are coming. My family, my mom is coming. My aunt, her sister, their friends.
今天是我的新娘送礼会。母鸡们都要来。我的家人，我妈要来。我姨妈，她姐妹，她们的朋友。
Hey Caroline, hey girl.
嘿卡罗琳，嘿女孩。
My nieces, my daughter's friends are coming to my bridal shower, and Rambo.
我的侄女们，我女儿的朋友都要来参加我的送礼会，还有兰博。
Y'all got your dollars ready? Your 5's and 10's?
你们准备好美元了吗？你们的5元和10元纸币？
Rambo is the stripper. He's coming all the way from Atlanta, Georgia. And he comes out in this expensive Armani suit, walking around, eyeballing the women, and talking business to them. So everybody, we've been practicing, "Rambo, Rambo, Rambo." Then we going to do the Xena yell, "La-la-la-la."
兰博是脱衣舞男。他远道从佐治亚州亚特兰大过来。他穿着昂贵的阿玛尼西装出场，走来走去，盯着女人们看，跟她们谈生意。所以大家，我们一直在练习，“兰博，兰博，兰博”。然后我们要发出西娜尖叫，“啦-啦-啦-啦”。
So this is Jeri Bello. And I invited Jeri today to pray over this, to pray for my sister to be happy with her new husband. So that's why I invited Jeri here today. Now I'm going to turn it over to Jeri Bello.
这位是杰里·贝洛。我今天邀请杰里来为这一切祈祷，为我妹妹能和新丈夫幸福祈祷。这就是我今天邀请杰里的原因。现在我把时间交给杰里·贝洛。
God bless everybody here. Well, I give honor to God today and to the future bride, the future groom in his absence. I just want to share a word, and it's on marriage. A sacrament is an act instituted by God for us to observe, so that we, the people, can receive divine strength.
上帝保佑在座的各位。好吧，今天我向上帝表达敬意，也向未来的新娘、缺席的未来新郎表达敬意。我只是想分享一句话，关于婚姻。圣事是上帝为我们设立的行为，以便我们所有人都能获得神圣的力量。
[SOUND OF THE XENA YELL]
[西娜尖叫声]
Come on, y'all. Rambo. Rambo. Rambo. Rambo. Rambo.
来吧，各位。兰博。兰博。兰博。兰博。兰博。
[SOUND OF WOMEN YELLING AND CHEERING]
[女人们的尖叫和欢呼声]
Tell me what you think about your baby and the pictures.
告诉我你对你的孩子和那些照片怎么看。
I have ultrasound pictures of Gerald's baby. It's a girl. Gerald's going to have a little girl.
我有杰拉尔德孩子的超声波照片。是个女孩。杰拉尔德要有个小女儿了。
Who's she look like to you?
在你看来她像谁？
People saying that she look like me by the nose and the lips.
人们说从鼻子和嘴唇看她像我。
She sure do.
确实很像。
She's big. You can see her head, her nose, and her lip. And she look like she got fat cheeks.
她很大。你能看到她的头、鼻子和嘴唇。看起来她有胖乎乎的脸颊。
How you feel about having a baby girl on the way?
你对于即将有个小女儿是什么感觉？
It feel OK.
感觉还行。
I have to say, I'm kind of excited. I'm not so depressed like I used to be when I thought about Gerald being a father. I guess with babies, when you see the babies, it makes it all right.
我得说，我有点兴奋。我不像以前想杰拉尔德当爸爸时那么沮丧了。我想对于婴儿，当你看到婴儿时，一切就都好了。
So what are you going to do? How you going to be a father? What type of father are you going to be?
那你打算怎么办？你打算怎么当爸爸？你会成为什么样的父亲？
A good father.
一个好父亲。
What is your definition of a good father?
你对好父亲的定义是什么？
To be there for my baby like a father should do.
像父亲应该做的那样陪伴我的孩子。
What should a father do? You tell me. What should a father do?
父亲应该做什么？你告诉我。父亲应该做什么？
I don't know. Like the fathers on TV, I guess. I don't know yet.
我不知道。就像电视里的父亲吧，我想。我还没想好。
I told Gerald when I get some extra money, I'm going to take him shopping and get things, so he can feel good about himself. Because he kind of lost it the other day. Kind of scared me too, the way he was crying. Because he is no longer in the STEP program.
我告诉杰拉尔德，等我有额外的钱，我要带他去购物买东西，这样他能感觉好点。因为他那天有点失控了。他哭的时候也把我吓坏了。因为他不再是STEP项目的成员了。
He's in regular classes because his test scores were so high. And he says, "The classes are too hard. They're too hard. I can't do it. I got a baby on the way. I don't know. I don't think I'm a dummy." And he was just going on and on and just scaring the hell out of me.
他在普通班上课，因为他的考试成绩太高了。他说：“课程太难了。太难了。我做不到。我有孩子要出生了。我不知道。我不觉得我是个笨蛋。”他一直在说，真的快把我吓死了。
Are you scared?
你害怕吗？
I don't know. I still like that. I'm kind of ready though.
我不知道。我还是喜欢那样。不过我已经准备好了。
But I let him know that everybody goes through that. And he's going to make it. All he had to do was study harder and don't give up. And I know he's going to turn out to be a  good father.
但我让他知道每个人都会经历那个阶段。他会成功的。他所要做的就是更努力学习，别放弃。我知道他会成为一个好父亲的。
When you look at those pictures, what do you think?
当你看着那些照片时，你在想什么？
I can't wait. That's what I think. I can't wait 'til the baby comes.
我迫不及待了。这就是我想的。我迫不及待等到孩子出生了。
And I told him, "I got your back. I'm gonna do what I can. Don't worry. Momma got your back."
我告诉他：“我会支持你的。我会尽我所能。别担心。妈妈支持你。”
That story was recorded by Barbara Clinkscales and was produced by Elise Spiegel with funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting. Gerald is currently speaking with Keisha's family again. They're sitting here in the studio with me as I say these words. She looks great. Her baby is due the first week of the new millennium.
那个故事是由芭芭拉·克林克斯凯尔斯录制的，由伊莉丝·斯皮格尔制作，并获得了公共广播公司的资金支持。杰拉尔德目前正在和基莎的家人沟通。当我录下这些话时，他们正和我坐在一起。她看起来棒极了。她的预产期在新千年的第一周。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, or listen for free at our website, www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果您想购买本节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380，或免费访问我们的网站www.thislife.org收听。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who makes this sound at the end of every show:
WBEZ管理层负责人是托里·马拉蒂亚，他在每期节目结束时都会发出这个声音：
[SOUND OF THE XENA YELL]
[西娜尖叫声]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给您更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。